[CROWD TALKING]
SARA ROBINSON:
All right, I think
we're going to go
ahead and get started.
Can everybody hear OK?
Awesome.
So today I'm going to tell
you all about building
iOS apps with Firebase.
Just a quick show of
hands, how many of you
have heard of Firebase before?
OK, about half the room.
How many people have built
an app with Firebase?
All right, just a few of you.
Before we get started, a
little bit about myself.
I am a developer advocate on
the Google Cloud platform team.
My name is Sara Robinson.
You can find me on
Twitter @SRobTweets.
And I live here
in San Francisco.
I'm a Swift fan, both Taylor
Swift and the language Swift.
If I had to choose a favorite
it would be a tough call.
All my code samples and demos
today are going to be in Swift.
And when I'm not
programming I can
be found finding the best
ice cream in San Francisco.
So here's what we're
going to cover today.
First, I'll give you an
overview of what Firebase is.
Then I'll talk
about specifically
how to get started
with Firebase on iOS.
And we'll do a quick
real-time chat demo.
Then we'll do another
demo of a visualizer
for the cloud vision robot
using Firebase on iOS.
And then we'll wrap up.
Before we dive
into the agenda, I
want to start by
telling a story.
So about a year
ago I didn't know
any native mobile development
and I really wanted to learn.
I had done a lot of JavaScript.
I had done some stuff with
hybrid mobile frameworks, which
lets you write HTML,
CSS, and JavaScript,
and it runs in the
native web view.
But I had never done any
native mobile development.
I've been an iPhone
user for a long time
so I decided I wanted
to learn iOS development
and I had a couple requirements.
I wanted a way to learn that
I could learn pretty quickly
and focus on learning
the iOS specific aspects
of development.
So I wanted to learn
how Xcode worked.
When I built apps I
didn't want to have
to focus on spinning up servers,
or working on my back end
infrastructure.
And Firebase turned out to be a
really great tool for learning
iOS development, which is
why I want to tell all of you
about Firebase today.
So now back to the agenda.
What is Firebase?
Firebase is a platform for
building extraordinary apps.
What does that mean?
Firebase consists of
three core features,
and the first of those
is a real-time database.
I'm going to talk about
all these in detail
but the Firebase database
is a NoSQL, JSON database.
And every piece of
data stored in Firebase
is referenced by a URL.
The second feature of Firebase
is user authentication.
So how many of you have
implemented OAuth before?
A few of you.
How many of you enjoyed it?
One person.
It's not very fun.
But the cool thing
about Firebase
is Firebase makes user
authentication easy.
So we take care of OAuth
on the Firebase servers.
All you have to do
is one method call,
different on each platform, and
you've got users authenticated.
You'll see that in demo shortly.
And then the last
feature Firebase offers
is static hosting.
So this is a tool
for web developers
to deploy static content,
HTML, CSS, and JavaScript
through the command line
with just one command,
Firebase deploy.
And your app is live on your
own Firebase app .com domain.
So let's take a look at
the real-time database.
First, I want to talk about
the ability of Firebase
to allow devices to talk
directly to the database.
So what we have here is
your traditional application
architecture.
We've got a device that talks to
an application server, which is
running your application logic.
And then this in turn
talks to the database.
With Firebase the
architecture is going
to look a little different.
With Firebase we have a
two-tier architecture.
So your device can talk directly
to the Firebase database.
And this simplifies
development a lot.
With this two-tier architecture
development is much faster.
So typically building real-time
apps is something that's
pretty difficult. We have
things like Google Docs
where users are adding notes
to documents in real time.
There's a team of hundreds
of engineers behind that.
With Firebase you can
build real-time app
as just a single developer or
a small team of developers.
So development is really fast.
And then Firebase handles
all the hard parts for you
so you don't have to worry
about scaling your app
from your first 10 users
to your first 10,000
if your app is a smash hit.
Firebase will take care of
the scaling part for you.
But sometimes you will want
to run trusted server code.
A lot of the Firebase
customers do.
So Firebase has a REST API that
lets you connect your server
code to Firebase.
And it's also really easy
to wire up third party APIs
with Firebase if
you'd like to do that.
So my favorite
part about Firebase
is the real-time data
synchronization, which you
can see from this awesome gif.
So the cool thing
about Firebase is
that any client that is
connected to your app
shares one master
copy of the data.
Any client that
subscribes to that
will see data
updates in real time.
So you don't have to pull
to refresh on mobile,
you don't have to refresh
the page on the web.
Data is synchronized in real
time, which is really cool.
So I've talked a
little bit about it.
Let's look at some Swift
code on how you would store
and sync data in Firebase.
So as I mentioned before,
every piece of data in Firebase
has its own URL.
So to create a reference
to your database
you say, let ref, so it's
going to be a constant here,
of type Firebase.
And you pass it a URL.
This is the URL I'm going
to use for this demo.
And there's two ways to
write data to Firebase.
The first is set value in swift.
And what this will do is
it'll update the location
with whatever you pass it.
You can pass it a string, an
object, a number, a Boolean,
and it'll update that.
So set value is useful
in certain situations.
Sometimes you'll
have a lot of people
writing to the same path
in your Firebase database
at the same time.
And in this case, you'll want to
generate a unique ID each time
a new piece of data is added.
Which is where you want to use
this method child by auto ID
in combination with set value.
So here what we're
doing is we're saying,
ref dot child by
auto ID, which is
going to create a path at
the root of your Firebase,
slash a unique
ID, which is going
to look something like what
you see in the comment there.
And then you're going to
set the value at that path.
Here we're just setting it
to a string, "Hello again!".
So that's how you
write data to Firebase.
To read data back
is pretty simple.
You just attach this
asynchronous callback
to your Firebase reference.
And this will be triggered any
time the data at that location
changes.
So you pass this
listener and event type.
Here we're using the
value event type.
This function is going to
be called any time the value
at that Firebase
location changes.
And because Firebase is
a real-time data stream,
it's always changing, this
will be passed as snapshot.
So it's a snapshot of your data
at that specific point in time.
And here we're just printing
the value of the snapshot
to the console.
So now let's take a look at
Firebase's authentication
feature.
Firebase has three different
types of authentication.
You can do basic
e-mail password auth,
and you can also
integrate with a number
of third-party providers.
So if you'd like to add Google,
Facebook, Twitter, or GitHub
Auth to your app.
It's really easy to
do this with Firebase.
All you need to do is
register your application
with one of these services,
grab your API key in secret,
head on over to your
Firebase dashboard,
paste your API key in secret in
there, and then just one method
call.
You're able to authenticate
users really easily.
And then finally, Firebase
offers anonymous auth.
Which is great if
you want to require
user login without having
users type in credentials.
So if you want to
generate guest user
accounts and still
have some notion
of securing your data without
requiring users to log in.
Let's take a look
at some code here.
This example we're using
GitHub authentication.
So we just call the message
auth with OAuth provider.
We pass it the provider
we want to use,
in this case it's GitHub.
We'll pass it our access token.
And then this is going to return
either an error or an auth data
object.
The auth data will
contain a bunch of data
from the GitHub user's profile.
And so you're
probably wondering,
if I'm talking from the device
directly to the database,
how do I secure my data?
How do I make sure
that people can't
write to other user's nodes?
And the way you do this
is through security rules.
So Firebase has a powerful
security language.
All of the security rules are
run on the Firebase servers,
and they're written in
JSON-like syntex that's
going to match to the structure
of your data in Firebase.
So let's say you have a slash
user's node in your Firebase.
That dollar variable dollar
UID signifies a dynamic path.
So this rule is going to apply
to any child of slash users.
There's three types of
security rules in Firebase.
The first is a read rule.
So this is saying that
the data at slash users
slash UID is globally readable.
Anyone can read
the data, but it's
only writable by
that specific user.
So when you use
Firebase authentication
in combination
with security rules
you automatically get access
to this Auth variable.
So I can do things like say,
only this specific user can
write to their own user node.
So this makes it possible
to say that you can't
spoof other users in the app.
The third type of rule
is a validation rule.
Those are run after the
right rule succeeds.
You can do things like verify
that the new data is a string,
is a number, adheres
to a certain length,
and things like that.
So a common problem on mobile
is what if your application
goes offline?
So let's say you got a
chat app that you built
and your users are on a train
that goes through a tunnel,
they lose connectivity,
they're climbing a mountain,
they're on a plane,
wherever they
may be they're going to
expect that their app will
work offline.
So how does Firebase
handle offline situations?
So any data center
while offline is
persisted to disk in
Firebase, not just to memory,
which is really powerful.
And when you regain
connectivity all of the data
you sent while offline will be
sent to the Firebase servers
and you'll also pull
down any data that was
sent while you were offline.
So I can talk about
offline disk persistence
but it's better
demonstrated with a demo.
And I didn't want to turn Wi-Fi
off during the presentation,
so I prerecorded this one.
So what you're
going to see here is
we'll add one message
while we're online.
Then I'll turn the Wi-Fi
off, add another message,
and then you'll see what happens
when I turn it back on again.
So let's go ahead
and play this video.
So you can see I'm online right
now adding a chat message.
It was added to Firebase.
And now I'm turning my Wi-Fi
off, adding another message.
Here we go, "Hello
from the other side".
And it was added to my app.
I quit the app.
Wasn't added to Firebase yet
because I'm still offline.
You can see it's
still saved there.
I'm turning my Wi-Fi back on and
boom, it was added to Firebase.
So that's a quick demo of
how Firebase offline works.
And to enable this, you
just need one line of code.
This is what it
looks like in Swift.
So you just say Firebase
dot default config and set
persistence enabled to true.
That's all you need to
do to get that working.
And then optionally
you can specify
that data at a specific
location in your Firebase
should be pre-fetched
and kept up to date.
And you can do that with
reft dot keep synced
and set that to true.
So now I want to talk about
the third feature of Firebase,
which is the static
hosting service.
And this lets you deploy
your static assets
through the command
line with just one
command, Firebase deploy.
And all the content is
served over HTTPS by default.
Firebase takes care of
acquiring the SSL cert for you.
It's backed by a global CDN
and custom domain support
is available.
So by default you get access to
your own Firebase app dot com
domain.
You can easily configure
a custom domain
if you'd like to host your
personal site on Firebase.
It's really easy to do this once
you've installed the Firebase
command line tools.
You just need to
run Firebase in it.
This will initialize
your directory
with Firebase hosting.
You only ever have to run that
command once for each project.
And then after that to
deploy is just one command,
Firebase deploy.
It's really fast.
So just to summarize, Firebase
has three client libraries.
iOS and Android
libraries for mobile.
I'm going to be focusing
on the iOS client today.
And then a JavaScript
client if you'd
like to build web
applications with Firebase.
And if you're a
JavaScript developer,
Firebase has libraries
for integrating
with popular front end
frameworks like Ember, Angular,
Backbone, and React.
So you can use those
frameworks for the front end
of your application
and then store
all of your data in Firebase.
And then Firebase
also has a REST API
so you can access it from your
favorite server side language.
So now I'd like to
talk specifically
about how you can get
started with Firebase on iOS.
Any iOS developers in the room?
Just out of curiosity.
OK, a handful.
The easiest way to use Firebase
on iOS is through CocoaPods.
For those of you
that aren't familiar,
CocoaPods is the iOS
dependency manager.
And so the way you do
this is you add Firebase
to your pod file.
This is where you describe
all of your dependencies
for your application,
with the correct version.
Then you go to your
application directory,
just run the
command pod install.
That will install
all the pods you've
defined in your pod file.
And then be sure to open
the xcworkspace version
of your project which will
include all the pods for you.
And then in your
view controller,
if you're using swift,
all you need to do
is add a Firebase import
and you're ready to go.
So now we're going to
go into a live demo.
What are we going to build?
We are going to build a
simple real-time chat app.
And it's going to look
something like this.
Similar to the
video I just played.
It'll be a basic UI table
view, which is just a list.
When you click on
the plus sign, you'll
be able to add a new
message and the messages
will be displayed
in the table view.
We're going to use
anonymous authentication
in the application so that I can
show you a little bit about how
Firebase authentication works.
Why would you want to use
anonymous auth in an app?
Let's say you have
a situation where
you don't want to
require users to log in,
but you want to have
some form of auth.
So you want to have
guest accounts.
Anonymous auth would
be great for that.
And also, with anonymous
auth you still get access
to Firebase's security rules.
So if you want to
enforce security rules
without requiring
user credentials,
anonymous auth is
a great way to go.
So I'm going to
quickly show video
of how to install Firebase with
CocoaPods, and then will get up
and running with some code.
So we're running pod in it.
This will create
a pod file for us.
So now I'm opening the pod
file, uncommenting those lines
and adding the Firebase pod
with the correct version.
And I'm going to save
and close the pod file.
And then run pod install.
I'm installing Firebase.
And now I can see the
xcworkspace version
of my project, which
I'm going to open.
And that is it.
That is all you have to do
to install the Firebase pod.
So now if we could
go to the demo.
Cool.
So I've already got a version
of this application running
that doesn't use Firebase.
Let's run it in the simulator
and see how it goes.
There you go.
So I'm going to
add a chat message.
I'm going to say, hello.
You can see it appears there.
I'm going to say, hello again.
It's there, but if I quit
the app and reopen it
my message is gone,
which is kind of sad,
it was only saved locally.
We want our chat to be
persisted somewhere which
is why we want to add
Firebase to the application.
So let's see how
we would do that.
So as you saw in the
video all I need to do
is add a Firebase import.
I've already installed
Firebase pod.
And then the next step is to set
up my Firebase reference, which
is going to go to this URL.
And let's actually take a look
at that URL in the browser.
So this is what my Firebase
database looks like.
Let me make that a
little bit bigger.
This is where all the
data from my application
is going to be stored.
I haven't added any
security rules yet,
but I'll do that shortly.
And in the log in
and off tab here
you can see that if I
go to anonymous auth
I have it enabled, which means
I have access to that function
to authenticate
users anonymously.
Let's go back to the data
and to the application.
And the first
thing we want to do
is, instead of adding the
messages to our local messages
array right when the alert
controller is cleared,
we're going to add that
in a different function.
So I'm going to get rid of this.
We're not going to reload
the table view there anymore.
We are going to instead
do that in this push
to Firebase function.
So what we have here is
a local messages array
and that's what we're using
to populate our table view.
So if we go down here.
Before we write that
push to Firebase
function the first
thing we want to do
is authenticate our users.
And we're going to do
that in view did load.
This is called only once in
our application lifecycle.
So I'm going to say ref
dot auth anonymously
with completion block.
And what this is going to do is
it's going to return an error
and and auth data object.
And here we're going to say
if error is not equal to null,
so if there's an
error let's just
print the error to the console.
Otherwise, let's
print auth data.
Obviously we want to do
something else with auth data,
but I'm just going to show
you what that auth data
object looks like first.
So here we can see
we've got this auth data
object with our unique
ID for that session.
So instead of printing
it, I'm going to say,
self dot UID equals
auth data dot UID.
And this self dot
UID is a variable
I have defined up here.
So now that we've got
users authenticated,
the next thing we want to
do is push that message
to Firebase with the user's UID.
So I'm going to create
here an object that's
going to have a key of text
and a value of text, which
is the text that the user has
inputted into that message box.
And then we're going to
have a key of user which
is going to have a value of
that UID that we set up here.
And then to write
this data to Firebase
is just one line of code.
So I'm going to say ref
dot child by auto ID.
And I'm using child
by auto ID because I'm
going to have a lot
of messages being sent
if this app is a smash hit.
And I want them to each
have their own unique ID.
So I'm using child
by auto ID and then
I'm going to say set value
message data, that data object
that I've defined right here.
So let's run this again.
And I think would be cool if
we had Firebase side by side
here with our chat demo.
So I'm going to
say, hello GCP next.
And we can see that my
message is added to Firebase.
Just one line of code with
my unique anonymous user ID.
If I add another
message, hello again.
We can see that it was
also added to Firebase,
which is pretty cool.
But you'll notice that
nothing updated in our UI
because we haven't written
a listener to read data back
from Firebase yet.
So that's what we
want to do next.
So going back to the code.
We're going to do this
in view did appear.
And what we're going to
do is every time the value
that this Firebase
is updated we're
going to add the messages
to this local array
and then we're going to update
the messages array up here
to contain the contents
of that local array
so that our table view will have
all the latest message data.
So here I'm going to say
ref dot observe event type.
And here I want to use the
child added event type.
Instead of value this
will be triggered
any time a new child is added
to my Firebase reference.
And here we're going
to get back a snapshot.
And first, let's just print
the value of that snapshot
so that you can all
see what it looks like.
This will be called once
for the initial data
and then it's called again
any time the data changes.
So let's play that.
And we can see what we got back
here is all the objects which
are currently in Firebase.
So instead of printing it
here what we want to do
is we want to grab
the value at the texts
and add that to our local array.
So let's write
the code for that.
So we're going to
say, let message text
equal snapshot dot
value dot object for key
as a method we have access to.
And I want to grab the
object at the key of text.
And I know that's always
going to be a string.
So I'm going to
downcast it to a string
and then I'm going to say
a local array dot insert
message text at index 0.
I'm using an insert
here instead of a pen
because I want to show the
most recent messages first.
So I'll insert it at index 0.
And then I want to say self dot
messages equals local array.
So I'm going to set
the global messages
array to this local
array which I'm using
to populate my UI table view.
And then I'm going to say self
dot table view dot reload data.
And we reload the
table view data.
So let's see this in action.
We're building it.
And here we have
in the simulator
we rendered all those
messages that we just sent.
So let me again pull up
Firebase side by side.
And let's see what happens
when I add a new message.
Woohoo!
And see that my message
was added in real time
and was also added to
Firebase, which is pretty cool.
So we've enabled real-time
sync with just a couple lines
of code.
And just to quickly show you
the cross-platform nature
of Firebase what I've got
over here is a JSFiddle.
And so I'm going to write
a super simple JavaScript
application that's connected
to the same Firebase.
And we'll see it update
in the simulator.
So here I'm going
to use JavaScript.
I'm going to say, bar
ref equals new Firebase,
and I'm going to create a
reference to the same Firebase.
GCP Next dot
Firebase io dot com.
And then I'm going
to say ref dot push.
Text is going to be
hello from JavaScript.
And let's run that.
And we can see
that updated here.
And it was also
added in Firebase.
But one thing you'll
notice is that it
doesn't adhere to the schema
that I was following here
where it has a text
and a user child key.
And this is where security
rules would come in handy.
So with security rules
you can see over here,
I'll make this full screen.
By default my
Firebase is globally
readable and write-able.
Which is not good.
That means anyone
can read and anyone
can write to the database here.
So I should add
some security rules.
So I'm going to do that now.
So I'm going to use
a dollar variable
to say that for any child
of the rue to my Firebase
this rule should apply.
So I'm going to say to
write to this node we
have access to--
new data is going
to be whatever data is added.
New data dot has children.
And they were going to
say that it needs to have
a text and a user key there.
So if I save the rules.
Rules are saved.
And I go here to
the JSFiddle and try
to add the data will see
that it did not succeed
because of my security rules.
But if instead I come in here
and say user Sara and run this
it was called again.
So now we're adhering
to my security rules.
One other thing I'd like
to add in my security rules
here is I want to make use
of the authentication which
I've added.
So I want to say that autho
cannot be equal to null.
So you need to be authenticated
to write to this Firebase.
So now if I go back to my
Fiddle and try to run this,
even though this has a
text and a user child key,
it's not going to succeed
because I'm not authenticated
from the JSFiddle.
So I just wanted to
show you how easy it is
to build cross-platform apps.
You can easily build an
iOS, Android, and web app
that all do the same thing
as long as they're connected
to the same Firebase database.
And again we did that in
just a couple lines of code.
So if we could go
back to the slides.
Let's see another app.
So you saw a pretty
simple use case.
A real-time chat up that
updates a UI table view.
Let's see an app that's a
little bit more complex.
The next thing that
we're going to look at
is an app I built which is
a dashboard for visualizing
the cloud vision robot.
How many of you have been
outside and seen the vision
robot at the conference?
Cool.
If you haven't
yet, there's still
time to check it
out after my talk.
For those of you that
haven't seen it yet,
you're probably wondering
what is this cloud vision
robot you're talking about.
It is an image
detection robot which
is powered by the
cloud vision API.
It looks like this.
It's name is vBot.
And this is a little
bit about how it works.
So it's a go pi
go robot that has
a raspberry pi running on it.
And the raspberry pi is
running some python code.
You can think of the raspberry
pi as the brain of the robot.
And the raspberry pi also
has a camera connected to it.
So the camera takes a picture
of whatever is in front of it.
And then it sends it
to the cloud vision
API which is able to
return a bunch of metadata
on what's in the object.
So we're using the vision
API's label and face
detection features here to
return some JSON on what's
in the image.
So if there's faces
in the image it
can tell where they are, if
the person is happy or sad.
And if there's
objects in the image
it can tell what
those objects are.
So the vision API returns
this JSON response.
And then we write that
JSON data to Firebase.
And we're using Firebase
to power the web dashboard.
So if you've seen
the vision bot you'll
see a dashboard that
looks something like this
on the monitors nearby.
And it displays
the latest picture
that was taken with the
bot along with the words
that it's seeing.
So you've got a web app
to visualize the robot.
And what we want to
add is an iOS app.
So I've taken the robot to
a couple of events so far.
And I thought it would
be cool, sometimes I'm
walking between
different demo booths,
I'm walking between venues and
I want to check up on the bots,
make sure they're all up and
running like they should be.
So I thought I'd
be cool to build
an iOS app that does something
similar to what the web
app does.
This is what the app
is going to look like.
It's going to be a basic
master detail view application.
So you've got a
UI table view that
showing the ID of all
of the active bots.
And then when you
click on one of the IDs
it'll show the detailed view
of what that bot is looking at.
So here's a picture I took
at my desk a couple days ago.
You can see it recognized my
face and that I was smiling.
So it drew a green
box around my face.
And I was holding up
a bottle of water.
The vision API was
able to identify that
as a bottle of water.
So what is the data going
to look like in Firebase?
So at the root of
our Firebase we
have a slash bots node
and then under that we
have all the IDs for our bots.
And whenever one
is updated we want
to change the color of that
cell and display how long
ago the bot was last active.
So here, if it was active
in the last 60 seconds
I'm displaying an active now.
That's what the
table looks like.
And this is a simplified
version of what the table view
controller code will look like.
So the first thing
that we're doing
is creating a reference
to our Firebase.
And then we're going
to create a local bot
array of f data snapshot.
F data snapshot is the
data type of the snapshot
that is returned from Firebase.
And then what we
want to do is we
want to sync that data from
Firebase into a local array.
So this is pretty
similar to what
I did before but we're listening
on the value event type.
And then we're going to loop
through all the bot IDs.
So we're going to say, for a
bot in snapshot dot children.
And then within
this function we're
going to sync all the
data to a local array.
And I'll show you it
in Xcode momentarily.
So then what will the data in
our detailed view look like?
So this is all the data
we're storing for each bot.
A bunch of different data.
And this is all data that's
returned from the vision API.
So if you look at
that slash face node,
the vision API returns a
bunch of data on the emotions
that it detects in the image,
where specific features are
in your face.
And then we're storing
all this in Firebase
along with the basic
C4 encoded image
string of the latest image.
And then we're also
storing all the labels
that the vision API
finds in Firebase.
So we want to loop through
those labels and display them.
The vision API also
returns a confidence score
of how confident it is that
it found that specific label
in the image.
So we'll display that
in the UI as well.
And this is what our detail view
controller code will look like.
So we create a reference to,
not to the root of our Firebase,
but to the specific
path for that bot.
So this is going to be slash
bot slash whatever bot ID.
And Firebase references
are inexpensive to create.
So we can create a
new ref for each bot
when that bot cell is clicked.
And so then on
that bot ref we're
going to listen again
on the value event type.
And then we're going to
grab all the data that's
being returned from the vision
API and store that in a vision
data object.
And then we're going to get the
basic C4 encoded image string.
We want to decode that
and then display it
in our UI image view.
And then we're going to
get all of the labels.
loop through the labels
and display those
in the UI as well.
So just to show you what the
format of the data looks like.
I've got a few sample responses
from the cloud vision API.
So this is a picture
I took a couple
months ago of some
beignets in New Orleans.
And I was pretty impressed
with the vision API's response.
It was able to identify
it as a beignet,
even though it's a super close
up photo that may not even
look like desert.
But it said beignet.
It was 92% sure.
It also said desert
and powdered sugar.
And then here's an example
of the face detection
response to a picture
I took with a friend.
So you can see it
returns the result
of the emotions it detected.
We can see that joy
likelihood was very likely.
It also returns a
landmarks object,
which includes a bunch of
different features in your face
and xy coordinates of where
those are in the image.
So now let's jump in to
live demo number two.
If we could switch
to my computer.
So I'm going to
minimize this app
and I'm going to
pull up-- actually
I'm going to stop
this from running.
I'm going to pull the bot app.
I'm actually going
to have Cathy come
up here to demonstrate this.
So Cathy here has a bot and
I'm going to run this app
and we're going to be able to
see what the bot is looking at.
So this I believe
is bot number 5574.
And we can see that she's
holding up a flower to it.
The lights are throwing
off a little bit but, could
be a Christmas decoration.
Daisy family.
There you go.
So there's the bot in action.
Thank you, Cathy.
That was awesome.
So this is what
the app is doing.
It's got a list of
all the active bots.
I can click on
them and then I can
see what they're looking at.
So that's kind of an overview
of what the app does.
Now I want to walk
you through the code
so that you can see a little
bit more complex app built
with Firebase.
So first, I want to show you
the table view controller.
So here we set up our
Firebase reference.
I've got a helper
class to do that.
And we want to have a
variable with the bot ID
because we're going to use this
when we segue from the table
view controller to the
detail view controller.
We want to pass that bot
ID so that we can create
our new Firebase reference.
And then we also have our local
bot array of f data snapshots.
So the first thing
we want to do is
in view did appear we're
going to attach our Firebase
listener.
And we're going to say, bot ref.
And Firebase has a
couple querying methods
which are pretty powerful.
They let you query
by an arbitrary child
key in your Firebase.
So here I am doing a
query ordered by key.
And remember all
the keys here are
going to be that list of bot
IDs which you saw in the slide.
And I only want to
query the box with IDs
starting between devrel
five and devrel six.
All the bots we brought to this
event have an ID of devrel five
with some other
numbers after it.
So I got this query here.
And I'm listening on
the value event type.
And the first thing
I do is I clear
that local bot array and I'm
going to add all the new bot
data to it.
So I'm going to loop through the
bots for bots and snapshot dot
children.
I'm going to say let bot snap
equal bot as f data snapshot
since we know it's going to
be of type f data snapshot.
And then we're going to
append that to the bot array
and reload the table view.
That's how we set
up our table view.
Here is where we write the
code to configure the cell.
So in this line we're
configuring the cell.
And then remember the cell
on the left side, the text
on the left was the bot's ID.
The text on the right was how
long ago the bot was active.
So here we've got
the bot time stamp.
We're grabbing
that from Firebase.
It's stored in
Firebase as a string.
So we need to actually calculate
how long ago the bot was
active.
So I've got a helper
method to do that.
And then we want to
configure the cell.
We'll set the text
label to the bot ID.
And we'll set the
detail text label,
which is the text that
appears on the right
to the active time stamp.
And then we want to change the
background color of the cell
depending on how long
ago the bot was active.
So the display is green
if the bot has been active
in the last minute.
And then the next thing
we do is set up our segue.
So here at did select
row at index path,
this is called whenever
a user selects one
of the rows in our table view.
We want to prepare our segue.
So we're going to set the ID
to whatever bot ID was selected
and then we're going to
perform the segue bot
lists to detail view.
And right here is
where we do that segue.
So in our destination
view controller
which is going to be the
bot detail view controller.
We're setting the name
on that view controller
to the bot's ID of the
bot that was selected.
And then here's
just the functions
we used to set up our table
view with our bot array data.
So once we perform
the segue we're here
in our bot detail
view controller, which
is pretty short.
So in here we're just
setting the title,
which is just the heading on
that view to the bots name.
And then we're creating
a new Firebase reference.
So this reference is going to
be slash bot slash whatever
bot ID we're viewing.
Devrel five in this example.
And then we're adding
another Firebase listener
to listen to the data only
for that specific bot.
So bot detail ref dot
observe event type.
We're listening
on the value type
again here because we're not
adding new data to this node,
we're just resetting the data
every time a new image is
taken by the bot.
So we're grabbing all the data
returned from the vision API.
We can think of this
as the bot's world.
So we store that with the key
of world, and then we basic
C4 decode the image since we're
storing the basic C4 image
string in Firebase.
And then we get
the labels that are
returned from the vision API.
And we loop through
them and we display them
so the description is going
to be whatever the label was
and then score is going
to be the confidence
score from the vision API.
And we're going to
display that as a percent.
We add that to the
label string and then
we just add some
styling to the UI label.
So again, I just
want to show you
an example of an app
built with Firebase
that's a little more complex
than just real-time chat.
And we can see that this
is super easy to do.
I've got a table view controller
and my detail view controller,
and all the data is displaying
in real time with Firebase.
So if we could go
back to the slides.
So just to recap, this
is what we covered.
We started with an
overview of Firebase.
Then I talked about how to get
started with Firebase on iOS.
And we did one demo,
a real-time chat.
Showed you how to update
a UI table view with chat
messages stored in Firebase.
And then we did a second demo
with the help from Cathy,
thank you Cathy, to show
a bot visualizer app
that I built to visualize all
the active cod vision bots
and what they're looking
at at that point in time.
So if you want to learn more
the Firebase documentation
is a great place to go.
They've got awesome docs for
every platform, iOS, Android,
and web, with detailed guides
on how to do all sorts of things
with Firebase.
And then if you want to learn
more about the vision API,
if you go to the Google
Cloud platform GitHub,
the cloud vision
repo has a bunch
of getting started samples
in all sorts of platforms
to get started with
the vision API.
There is an iOS sample
in Swift and Objective C.
And I encourage you to get
in touch with Google Cloud.
You can follow us on Twitter.
We have a slack channel.
And we've got a bunch of samples
for all sorts of cloud products
on the Google Cloud
platform GitHub.
And thank you all for coming.
That's all I've got.
[APPLAUSE]